[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition du journal le
premier sous le nouveau nom de votre
chaîne tv 60,18 la page téléphiles se
tourne et votre média d'information
locale confirme sa volonté de vous faire
vivre l'actualité de l'ensemble du
département dans les prochaines semaines
et prochains mois ah voici les titres de
ce 3 juillet emmanuel macron vient de
réunir les députés et sénateurs à
versailles premier discours pour le
nouveau président face aux élus de la
nation nous irons sur place dans un
instant
pendant ce temps le département poursuit
son rapprochement avec les
hauts-de-seine les conseillers
départementaux des yvelines ont adopté
ce vendredi
le regroupement avec le 92 à une
majorité écrasante seulement deux élus
sur 42 ont voté contre et puis elle nous
irons aussi au cours de ce journal à
maurepas à la commune vient de lancer sa
brigade équestre en partenariat avec l
encours de policiers municipaux à cheval
un représentant pour chaque commune
par contre on les rues de la ville
durant l'été afin d'assurer plus
efficacement la sécurité des habitants
le président de la république a donc
réunir le congrès ce lundi à versailles
un rendez vous pour donner les
principaux axes de son mandat avant même
le discours de politique générale du
premier ministre edouard philippe demain
est sur place cet après midi nicolas
quirion vite c'est patrick jacques de
dixmude wilfried après le discours du
président de la république qui aura duré
plus d'une heure ce sont désormais les
présidents des différents groupes
parlementaires de l'assemblée nationale
et du sénat qui s'expriment devant leurs
collègues ils sont à peu près 900 ici à
versailles et parmi ces 900 et lui il y
en a 18 du territoire à des yvelines 12
députés six sénateurs d'ailleurs scène
plutôt cocasse on en a croisé plusieurs
de venir directement à pied au congrès
privilège de la proximité oblige leurs
collègues eux venaient directement en
bus est des élus yvelinois 1 qui met les
pieds au congrès pour beaucoup pour la
première fois c'est le cas notamment et
des députés fraîchement élus lors des
élections législatives s'est en revanche
pas
cas pour les six sénateur des yvelines
qui eux ont connu le congrès de novembre
de françois hollande et qui ont aussi
pour certains connus les congrès
convoqué par nicolas sarkozy à l'époque
on attend désormais de les croiser pour
leur demander à ses élus aubinois ce
qu'ils ont pensé du discours du
président de la république le président
de la république s'est adressé
directement aux parlementaires en leur
indiquant qu'il souhaitait réduire leur
nombre d'un tiers ou d'installer aussi
une dose de proportionnelle des
propositions qui devrait être voté d'ici
un an peut-être par voie de référendum
c'est ce qu'a indiqué le président de la
république et qui serait donc effective
pour les prochaines élections et
notamment les élections législatives de
nicolas kirillovitch assisté de patrick
jacques de dixmude parmi les annonces
c'est d'emmanuel macro on retiendra
aussi la suppression de la cour de
justice de la république a noté que le
président souhaite revenir tous les ans
devant le congrès pour rendre compte de
son action
en marge de ce rendez-vous
parlementaires élus locaux et militants
communistes se sont rassemblés devant la
mairie de versailles d'autres forces de
gauche comme les jeunes socialistes ou
encore des représentants de la france
insoumise étaient présentes
un rassemblement pour dénoncer ce qu'ils
qualifient de coup d'état institutionnel
d' emmanuel macron le secrétaire général
du pcf pierre laurent et le président du
groupe parlementaire gauche démocrate et
républicaine
andré chassaigne en tête de cette
manifestation ainsi que la secrétaire
départemental de la fédération
yvelinoise du parti communiste vous
l'avez vu colette géré guen on les
écoute au micro pardon de nicolas landry
le message qu'on veut faire passer à
emmanuel macron c'est qu'ils remettent
qui met en chantier immédiatement
donc la réforme des institutions avec
l'inversion du calendrier électoral et
la proportionnelle à toutes les
élections pour que tout le peuple soit
entendu là emmanuel macron se comporte
comme un monarque en réunissant congrès
avant même que le premier ministre perd
ne prenne la parole pour que chacun
puisse se sentir représentés alors quand
on voit l'abstention actuelle on voit
bien que le système ne convient plus les
gens ne se sont plus ne semble plus
représentés par leurs députés et
politiques toujours c'est sans grande
surprise que les yvelines et les
hauts-de-seine ont voté vendredi dernier
à une majorité écrasante leur volonté de
fusionner l'union de ces deux
départements ne semble être dorénavant
qu'une formalité
elle charline hurel les images stéphane
servant c'est une journée historique
le mot est fort et signe peut être
l'aboutissement d'un projet né en 2015
la fusion des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine était votée ici à
versailles 40 voix pour et deux contre
un succès pour pierre bédier et patrick
devedjian les présidents des deux
départements que l'ouest est très
maltraitée par les pouvoirs publics
depuis fort longtemps ce n'est pas une
question de gauche ou de droite
mais depuis une cinquantaine d'années
l'ouest est oublié et en fusionnant en
regroupant nos forces bien nous voulons
remettre l'ouest à la fois dans le jeu
et être au service de cette ambition
métropolitaine notre complémentarité
notre efficacité et notre succès n'est
pas un thème de discours c'est une
démonstration arguments avancés pour le
projet la baisse drastique des dotations
de l'état
une fusion qui engendrerait un seul
budget 3,4 milliards d'euros au total
une somme à disposition pour financer
les grandes infrastructures ou encore
les transports
un argument financier qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité
si l'état est vraiment impécunieux à ce
point et qu'il va faire les poches des
départements il va peut-être commencer
aussi par les départements les plus
riches à savoir les hauts-de-seine ont
fait aujourd'hui un saut dans l'inconnu
c'est à dire qu'en réalité le président
nous avait annoncé que l'on prendrait le
temps de se rapprocher pas à pas nous
n'avons eu aucune
de travail d'approfondissement sur sur
ces enjeux et la fusion est arrivé et la
procédure est lancée aujourd'hui des
réserves partagées par les députés la
république en marge des yvelines le sort
des deux départements est maintenant
entre les mains du gouvernement
une fusion qui pourrait être effective
dès 2018 et l'a annoncé ce week-end de
benoît hamon quitte le parti socialiste
devant onze mille personnes réunies sur
la pelouse de reuilly à paris l'ancien
député des yvelines a lancé dans la
foulée la création de son mouvement du
1er juillet son objectif est de dépasser
les parties reconstruire la gauche
écoutez le je quitte ce parti parce que
j'ai acquis l'intimé conviction que je
serais plus utile en dehors de celui-ci
et nous avons désormais la
responsabilité de faire re vivre et de
faire vivre cet idéal auquel tant
d'entre nous sacrifie temps de leur
temps d'armer vous des milliers je crois
plus que jamais à la nécessité du combat
socialiste celui qui associe la conquête
des libertés la conquête des droits
sociaux elle encore est mort pas amen
depuis le 1er juillet une
expérimentation les deux polices
municipales se sont associés pour lancer
une brigade équestre les deux agents un
pour chaque commune patrouilleront tout
l'été près des lieux de détente
principalement mélanie poquet nicolas
landry cocktails et isi ont rejoint les
rangs ils sont les nouveaux agents des
polices municipales des longs cours et
maurepas
nous disposons d'un certain nombre de
lieux de détente plus fréquentées sur
cette période tels que sur la commune de
maurepas le bassin de la courance la
coulée verte sur elle en cours ce sont
des exemples la patrouille est prévue de
10 heures à 18 heures avec une
possibilité de décaler jusqu'à 22 heures
donc il s'agit de deux agents donc un
agent de la commune de maurepas un agent
de la commune d'el en cours tous deux
cavaliers et volontaire sur cette action
les deux trotteurs français viennent
d'un centre équestre proche de gambe et
des chevaux non mes motifs facilitant
les patrouilles
on a une allure qui est un peu plus
rapide que de marcher à pied
en mai en même temps suffisamment long
pour bien observer et on est beaucoup
plus aussi que quelqu'un qui à pied ou
sur un vélo donc on a un point de vue
beaucoup plus générale on peut notamment
regarder par-dessus les clôtures voir
l'arrière des maisons prendre les
petites sente piétonne ce qui nous
permet d'avoir un autre angle de
surveillance le dispositif coûte 4300
euros par commune
un bilan sera fait à l'issue pour
évaluer cette brigade
le bruit des sabots sont tendres a
jusqu'au 18 août et du sport à présent
avec ses images de l'open de france de
golf c'est l'homme en forme du moment il
l'a prouvé sur les greens du golf
national ces derniers jours tommy
fleetwood 26 ans 4e du dernier us open a
remporté la 101e édition de l'open de
france pour sa cinquième apparition à
saint quentin en yvelines à la première
depuis 2010 le fantasque britannique
totalise un score de -12 avec une carte
de 66 cinq coups sous le par
le dimanche je pense que c'était
vraiment important de bien jouer cette
semaine
tout le monde a joué un très bon niveau
pour avoir un bon résultat
le parcours était très agréable et cela
m'a permis d'avoir un swing très
performant à nouveau au rendez vous
musical a été inauguré ce week end à
voisins le bretonneux les plus anciens
se souviendront de la tour prend l'air
c'est la tour mais les watts dorénavant
qui prend le relais festival qui a réuni
une dizaine de groupes et programmation
plutôt éclectique pour une première
édition nicolas landry et camille
lambert
[Musique]
jusqu'à déjanté des riffs saturés et un
duo de didgeridoo la musique sous toutes
ses formes à voisins le bretonneux
pour sa première édition le festival la
tour mais les boîtes s'est offert une
programmation festive et varier un peu
éclectique cir est allé avec le style
différent ça permet de découvrir aussi
d'autres
dont celle de musique comprenait pas
forcément découvrir de nouveaux puits de
trous de découvrir de nouveaux styles de
nouveaux styles de son de comment les
gens ils font leurs sont tous a donc de
nouveau jean tard aussi pas mal
une dizaine de groupes de scène et des
artistes locaux en pleine performance
un événement pour faire revivre l'ancien
festival la tour prend l'air en mettant
à l'honneur musiciens amateurs et
professionnels ce qui a motivé à lancer
ce festival c'est le la volonté de
de promouvoir les groupes émergents
c'est pour la plupart cédés groupe qu'on
a
on a déjà fait jouer à la salle de la
tour la volonté c'était vraiment
d'offrir un plein air et redonner ses
lettres de noblesse à oui aux amateurs
et puis du coup avec l'avantagé d'avoir
la tête d'affiche qu'ils puissent
rameuter du monde et qui allume la fête
quoi et c'est à hilight tribe qui était
destinée cette tâche le groupe en tête
d'affiche très attendu des visiteurs a
clos le festival sur une note 36 quai
des tic
[Musique]
et
et retour également sur cette première
édition de la tour mais les watts dans
le 7-8 culture mercredi pour conclure ce
journal direction coignières la commune
organisée ce samedi 1er juillet elle sa
traditionnelle fête de la ville de
nombreuses animations sportives autour
du golfe et des jeux olympiques a
notamment au vu de la ryder cup et de
paris 2024 à saint quentin en yvelines
un moyen donc de promouvoir l'olympisme
avec le stand du comité départemental
olympique
il y avait au il y avait aussi des jeux
pour les enfants on écoute le maire de
la commune jean-pierre sevestre au micro
de nicolas landry on voit également bien
sûr le vivre ensemble bien vivre
ensemble et essayer de faire des
relations des relations entre entre
quale rien il compagnie aérienne bien
sûr mais pourquoi pas aussi haut avec
les communes du territoire et les
communes limitrophes et cette année nous
avons également un stand destiné à notre
plan local d'urbanisme car nous sommes
en cours d'élaboration ce plan local
d'urbanisme et nous avons voulu mettre à
disposition de la population qu'il
désire et bien les grandes orientations
1 les grandes orientations de la ville
d'ici à une vingtaine d'années merci
d'avoir suivi ce journal les programmes
se poursuivent sur tv à 78 replay sur
notre site internet prochaine édition de
votre journal d'actualités locales ce
sera mardi 18h
[Musique]